هذا المكان الذي نحن فيه في منطقه كهرمان
مرش في وسط منطقه كهرمان مرش هو واحد من
اكثر الاماكن تضررا في المدينه مبنى ربما
لاننا في ساعات الليل والاضاءه لا توجد
تعطي صوره كامله عن المبنى لكن المبنى هو
مربع سكني بالكامل تهدم
تدمر بالكامل عمليات الانقاذ تجري ايضا في
الجزء الاخر من هذا المبنى الاهالي اخبروا
انهم سمعوا اصوات واصوات ضرب على الاحجار
في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي تركز جهود
الانقاذ على هذه البنايه بالذات في محاوله
لايجاد
ناجين في هذا المكان
نحاول التقدم قليلا الى المكان سيبداون
بالمناداه على
الان يطلبه من الجميع عدم التحدث سيتم
المناداه
يتحدث مع الذين يعتقد انهم لا زالوا احياء
تحت الانقاذ يقول لهم
اضربوا حركوا ارجلكم اضربوا الاحجار اذا
لا تستطيعون تتحدثون هناك
الان يقول هل يوجد احد في الداخل نعم
يطلبون الصمت
الان تم دفن 600 شخص
من اهالي كهرمان مرش ونحن نتحدث عن اشخاص
تم التعرف عليهم وتم الحصول على الموافقه
من عائلاته لدفنهم سيتم نصب
مباني سكنيه جاهزه في مناطق قريبه لواء
النازحين هناك الالاف من العائلات وانا
شاهدت مئات السيارات تتواجد فيها عائلات
العائلات باتت تسكن داخل السيارات على
الطرقات وفي الاماكن القريبه فرص الوصول
الى ناجين تحت الانقاض لا تزال مستمره